[Music]  blood was shed on Tuesday night's  Bachelorette but turns out not between  Kenny and Lee on night 2 of the two-part  Bachelorette event on Tuesday  Rachel Lindsay sent Lee packing real  quick  during the drama filled two-on-one date  with single father Kenny I don't trust  you and Kenny went head to head with  Adam in a Viking throwdown during a  group date in Denmark that left both men  bloodied but Kenny the victor there's a  lot of things that Raceland talk about  but you know Viking change Kenny was  later sent home and it was emotional our  hearts melted when he broke down  revealing the news to his daughter Rach  kept it so 100 on Tuesday's episode she  sent a total of six guys packin Anthony  will Josiah and Alex were among the rest  of the cast that got the boot I had to  say a lot of hard goodbyes this week  this is honestly the hardest goodbye  then that I have to say  [Music]  you